hey guys it's vadim with maxtec and over
the last couple of days benchmarks for
apple's brand new m1 pro and m1 max
chips have been leaked and at first
glance they kind of look a bit
disappointing because they don't seem to
match up to our initial estimates and
predictions but the truth is actually
hidden in real world performance which i
will show you later so in this video i'm
gonna go through all of the leaked
benchmarks including ones for both the
m1 pro and m1 max chips and i'm also
going to compare them to other mac and
windows pc systems and then i'm going to
also look at some more realistic leaked
tests that show the true power of these
chips so getting right into the leaked
geekbench 5 benchmarks let's start with
the cpu side before going over to the
gpu as you can see we have some slight
variation in the scores with the highest
one giving us an astounding 1700
single core and 12
693 multi-core points now that score is
definitely not what we expected because
i personally predicted around 14 000
and a half multi-core points but then
again apple did confirm that the m1 pro
has a cpu that's just 70 percent faster
which almost perfectly lines up to the
leaked scores we're seeing here now the
big question is why we're not seeing in
almost doubling in performance like we
thought we would but before i dig deep
into that i want to compare those leaked
scores to other systems we actually have
a 12 core xeon mac pro in the office
which was able to score 12 518
multi-core points so the new m1 pro and
max chips are actually outperforming it
with just eight high performance cores
instead of 12 on the mac pro but making
things even crazier we measured the peak
wattage of the mac pro while running
geekbench 5 and it had a staggering
218 watts at one point in the test and
according to apple's own comparison
charts the new chips are limited to 30
watts of power so if you translate the
scores into performance per watt metrics
these new macbook pros are giving us
over seven times more performance per
watt which is mind-blowing now comparing
the league score to the previous fully
specced out 16-inch intel macbook pro
the new one is literally almost twice as
fast and going further one of my twitter
followers shared this image of a bunch
of intel and amd server chips and as you
can see the new m1 mac chips are faster
than almost all of them including the 32
core amd epic 7542 and another twitter
follower johnny mcclung who has his own
youtube channel shared the scores of his
16 core xeon mac pro and it was just
barely faster than apple's new 10 core
chip and finally comparing it to the
best x86 laptop ship out there the intel
i9 11 980 hk apple's new chip is much
faster so even though we're not getting
the performance we expected these new
macbook pros are still the fastest
laptops ever made but nevertheless the
truth is that apple is still limiting
these chips with a maximum of 30 watts
of power and we know that it's not due
to thermal throttling because geekbench
5 is a quick test that never really lets
the cpus heat up that much so it's got
to be a hard 30 watt cap by apple now
why would they do this well for two
different reasons one reason is because
of amdahl's law which basically means
that you get diminishing returns when
adding more cores for running programs
with parallel processing now the other
reason is probably because apple showed
that the 32 core m1 matched gpu uses 60
watts of power in their comparison
charts to other windows gpus so if you
add that 60 watts from the gpu to the 30
watts from the cpu you get a total of 90
watts of power usage if you're fully
maxing out both of them at the same time
which isn't likely to happen but it
still might for very intense workloads
and then if you consider the fact that
the best power adapter option available
with the 14 inch macbook pro is a 96
watt charger that would leave only 6
watts of extra power for the rest of the
system if you were theoretically maxing
out both the cpu and the gpu so apple
likely put a 96 watt total power cap on
the entire system to ensure that the
battery won't drain while you're
charging it so now the 30 watt power
limit on the cpu starts to make perfect
sense now before i get into all of the
gpu benchmark leaks the story for the
cpu doesn't end just yet the apple
developer steve moser was looking
through the beta of mac os monterey and
he found a brand new high power mode
setting which is the opposite of low
power mode steve ended up finding this
very interesting text from apple
themselves your mac will optimize
performance to better support resource
intensive tasks
this may result in louder fan noise so
that's great and all but the caveat is
that this mode is only available on the
16-inch macbook pro and only if you have
the m1 max chip which is very
interesting because the 14 inch can also
be configured with the same fully
specced out m1 max so with that said
what we have to figure out is what is so
special about the 16 inch model well the
16 inch is obviously much larger in
terms of the chassis size as well as
being thicker even though it packs the
same chip configurations which means
that the 16 inch has more internal space
to work with and yes the larger 100 watt
hour battery compared to 70 on the 14
inch does take up some room but there's
still some left over space so our theory
is that the 16 inch model with the m1
max chip actually comes with a better
cooling system and if you need some
proof for that theory here you go if you
look at the tech specs on the 16-inch
macbook pro the model with the m1 max
chip is actually heavier than the one
with the regular m1 pro chip so you
might be thinking that the difference is
explained by just the larger chip
however if you look at the 14 inch
model's tech specs there is no
difference in weight
between the two chips so what if you
truly do get a better cooling system on
the 16 inch model with the m1 max now
with that said another theory for this
16 inch model exclusively getting high
power mode is actually due to the power
adapter since the 14 inch model can only
have up to a 96 watt power adapter what
if apple will not allow the high power
mode on that machine because of the hard
96 watt power cap but they will on the
16 inch because it comes with an 140
watt power adapter which can recharge
faster who knows but either way the
point that i'm trying to make is that
there's still a chance we could see
better scores with high power mode
enabled if those leaked benchmarks were
not using it but what i can assure you
is that we will for sure be testing out
the new high power mode when we get in
our eight different macbook pro
configurations so be sure to subscribe
right now so you don't miss out and by
the way we just launched our brand new
m1 max tech t-shirt design which you can
find in the merge shelf below as well as
this sharpie edition design that i'm
wearing right now and be sure to use the
promo code m1 pro to get 20 off on all
of our merch now getting into the league
graphics benchmark scores the highest
one we saw was 68
870 points from that 32 core m1 max gpu
using the optimized metal framework now
at first glance that seems extremely
disappointing because i was personally
expecting around 80 to 90 000 graphics
points in this test so in reality this
leaked score doesn't seem that much
faster than the 42 500 points that the
previous intel macbook pros 5600 mgpu
scored and it's nowhere near the
performance of the fastest laptop gpu
which is the 3080 mobile which apple
compared the m1 max ship to in one of
their comparison charts but in reality
apple's new chips pack a ton of unique
and record-breaking hardware components
inside of them including an absolutely
insane 32 channels of memory and a very
impressive 400 gigabytes per second of
memory bandwidth so these raw gpu
benchmarks don't show the whole truth so
before i get into how this 32 core gpu
performs in the real world including
some more leaked tests i want to get
into the lower end 16 core gpu and the
less expensive m1 pro chip the best car
we got for this chip is 41
914 which is actually super impressive
and it's just barely shy of our
performance expectations being almost
exactly two times faster than the m1s 8
chord gpu which would mean it's getting
almost perfect scaling however the
really weird thing is that this leaked
score is actually lower than last year's
top of the line 5600 m gpu and this is
what finally brings us to the real world
leaked tests that show a totally
different picture in gfx bench 5.0 you
can now see that the 16 core m1 pro
outperforms the 5600m and basically
every test that we see here and some of
these are by huge margins like as much
as 50 faster which proves that the
geekbench drive benchmark isn't showing
us the full truth and even in apple's
own testing like 3d rendering using
maxon cinema 4d with redshift apple
shows the 16 core m1 pro being a
staggering two and a half times faster
than the 5600m and yes apple's notes
show that the 5600m was fully loaded
even with 64 gigabytes of ram and an 8
terabyte ssd now with that said you may
have noticed that on the same 3d
rendering chart from apple the m1 max
only gives you four times more
performance instead of the expected five
times if it's scaled perfectly so apple
is admitting that yes the 32 core gpu
has diminishing returns compared to the
16 core but don't worry because that
leaked 68 870 geekbench score isn't
telling you the truth because we just
got a set of leaked gfx bench benchmarks
and as you can see
there are many tests where this new 32
core m1 max gpu is actually
outperforming the 3080 mobile laptop gpu
because these tests are taking full
advantage of the m1 max chip package so
in reality do not trust those
disappointing looking geekbench scores
because it performs much better in real
world use cases so with all of that said
we can see that you're not getting as
much bang for your buck with the m1 max
chip compared to the m1 pro but that has
honestly always been the case with
graphics cards and it's exactly what we
expected so if you want the best value
get the m1 pro but if you want the
absolute most graphics power you can get
go for the 32 core m1 max so hopefully
you enjoyed this video and if you did go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and definitely check out our buyer's
guide video right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]